YOU SWITCHED ON ME.
THIS IS MY WIFE, THIS IS MY
SISTER.
THEY SWITCHED ON ME.
JESSE: THE NEW SUPERSTAR AT THE
PODIUM IS KEEPING HIM IN CHECK.
>> CHRIS CUOMO SAID SHOW ME
WHERE IT SAYS PROTESTERS ARE
SUPPOSE TO BE PEACEFUL.
I POINT HIM TO THE FIRST
AMENDMENT WHERE IT SAYS HE HAS
THE RIGHT TO FEASIBLE ASSEMBLY.
HE SHOULD READ THE CONSTITUTION.
YOU ARE ASKING THE WRONG
QUESTION.
THE RIGHT QUESTION IS -- CAN I
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
I ANSWERED IT ONCE.
DID ANYONE TAKE IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO POSE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT MICHAEL FLYNN AND THE
UNMASKING OF OBAMA’S
SPOKESPERSON.
I WAS ASKED PROBABLY 12
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE CONFEDERATE
FLAG.
AND I AM DISMAYED I DIDN’T
RECEIVE ONE QUESTION ON THE
DEATHS WE HAD IN THE COUNTRY
THIS WEEKEND.
I NEVER RECEIVED ONE QUESTION
ABOUT FIVE CHILDREN WHO WERE
KILLED.
>> THE PARENTS OUT THERE WERE
NOT ALLOWED -- WHAT AM I GOING
TO DO WITH MY KIDS?
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WANTS
SCHOOLS TO OPEN.
THE SCIENCE SHOULD NOT STAND IN
THE WAY OF THIS.
EVERYONE ELSE IN THE WESTERN
WORLD IS DOING IT.
SCIENCE IS ON OUR SIDE HERE.
JESSE: JIM ACOSTA TOOK TO
TWITTER TO TAKE A JAB AT
KAYLEIGH MCENANY AND SAID THIS.
SCIENCE SHOULD NOT STAND IN THE
WAY OF THIS.
TRY IT AGAIN.
YOU TOOK THE WORDS OUT MUCH
CONTEXT.
JOINING ME TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT.
KAYLEIGH MCENANY.
EVERYBODY SAW WHAT YOU WERE
SAYING.
THE SCIENCE IS ON THE SIDE OF
OPENING SCHOOLS AND THE SCIENCE
SHOULDN’T GET IN THE WAY OF
OPENING SCHOOLS BECAUSE SCIENCE
SUPPORTS RE-OPENING SCHOOLS.
BUT HE REFRAMES WHAT YOU SAID TO
MAKE YOU LOOK BAD.
DO YOU EVER JUST SEE HIM WALKING
AROUND AND KIND OF STICK A
FINGER IN HIS FACE AND SAY WHAT
THE HELL ARE YOU DOING?
>> I SEE HIM AROUND.
HE’S QUITE NICE OFF CAMERA.
THIS IS THE EQUIVALENT.
IF I WAS TO SAY TO YOU RIGHT
NOW, THERE IS NO UNIVERSE IN
WHICH JIM ACOSTA ENGAGES IN FAKE
NEWS AND YOU PUT UP ON YOUR
CHRYON, JIM ACOSTA ENGAGES IN
FAKE NEWS.
BUT THAT’S WHAT JIM ACOSTA DID.
THAT’S WHY HE CORRECTED HIS
TWEET.
JESSE: DR. HECKLE AND MR. HYDE
SITUATION.
THERE GUY CROSSING YOU IS
JONATHAN CARR.
HE RUNS THE WHITE HOUSE
ASSOCIATION’S CORRESPONDENTS.
HE DOESN’T LIKE THE WAY YOU RUN
THE BRIEFING.
HE WROTE THIS ANGRY COLUMN IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAYING YOU
OPEN THE BRIEFING LIKE YOU ARE
DOING A CABLE NEWS MONOLOGUE AND
YOU ARE NOT DOING YOUR DUTY.
YOU ARE NOT INFORMING THE
PUBLIC.
WHAT ELSE YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> HE LIKES TO TALK ABOUT THE
PUBLIC TRUST IN HIS OP-ED.
I USE THE BRIEFING TO HIGHLIGHT
THE ISSUES THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT THAT THEY DON’T ASK
ABOUT.
WHEN HAVE THEY ASKED ME ABOUT
POLICE OFFICERS DYING IN THE
STREETS.
CHILDREN DIE IN DEMOCRACIES.
WHEN HAVE THEY ASKED ABOUT THIS?
THEY DON’T ASK ABOUT IT.
IT’S WHY I LOOK OVER THE
REPORTERS DIRECTLY AT THE CAMERA
AND SPEAK TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
BECAUSE THESE ISSUES AND THESE
LIVES MATTER.
NO ONE IS STOPPING HIM FROM
TRYING TO BECOME PRESS SECRETARY
IN A FUTURE ADMINISTRATION.
JESSE: HE COULD HAVE BEEN PRESS
SECRETARY FOR THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION.
IS HE ONE OF THOSE GUYS WHO’S
NICE WHEN THE CAMERAS GO OFF?
>> JOHN IS NICE, TOO.
A LOT OF THEM ARE NICE OFF THE
CAMERA.
JESSE: YOU HAVE BEEN GETTING
INTO IT A LOT RECENTLY I GET THE
CHICAGO MAYOR HATES YOU NOW.
YOU SAID I GUESS SHE WASN’T
DOING HER JOB.
>> IT’S D IT’S IT’S UNACCEPTABLE
JESSE: SHE TWEETED "HEY, KAREN,
WATCH YOUR MOUTH."
I GUESS IT’S SLANG FOR A BOSSY
MIDDLE AGED WHITE WOMAN.
YOU DON’T LOOK MIDDLE AGED.
WHAT’S YOUR RESPONSE TO THE
MAYOR OF CHICAGO?
>> I’M UPSET ABOUT THE VIOLENCE
IN THE STREETS OF HER CITY.
RIGHT NOW THIS WEEKEND WHAT
WE’LL SEE HOPEFULLY NOT, BUT
WHAT HAVE ROUTINELY SEEN ARE
DOUBLE DIGIT NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
DYING IN HER CITY.
I UNDERSTAND THE TRUTH HURTS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS WRITTEN HER A
LETTER AND OFFERED HER HELP.
AND SHE NEEDS TO TAKE IT.
IT’S INEXCUSABLE WHEN CHILDREN
DIE ON THE STREETS OF CHICAGO.
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON THAT.
JESSE: HOMICIDES ARE
SKYROCKETING.
I THINK THEY ARE HAVING THE
DEADLIEST YEAR IN 25 YEARS.
IT’S NOT GOOD TO BE LIVING IN
CHICAGO RIGHT NOW.
THE PRESIDENT IT PIVOTING TO THE
ECONOMY AFTER A ROUGH START TO
THE SUMMER?
WE ARE SEEING THINGS RE-OPEN.
HE’S WEARING A MASK NOW.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT MASKS
IN THE NEXT SEGMENT.
IN YOUR OPINION, LOOKING FORWARD
TO AUGUST, THEN SEPTEMBER, WHAT
IS THE WHITE HOUSE DOING IN
ORDER TO BRING THIS COUNTRY BACK
TO FULL THROTTLE.
>> A LOT.
THIS IS A JOBS PRESIDENT.
WE ARE FOCUSING ON PHASE FOUR
WHICH WILL BE A GREAT BILL IF
THE DEMOCRATS COME TO THE TABLE.
THE PAYROLL TAX HOLIDAY IS WHAT
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO SEE, AND
MORE FUNDING FOR OUR SCHOOLS TO
RE-OPEN.
YOU LOOK AT THE VACCINE.
YOU HAVE ONE VACCINE ENTERING
PHASE THREE TRIALS.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS BROKEN DOWN
BARRIERS.
IT’S A STARK CONTRAST TO
DEMOCRATS WHO WANT TO LOCK OUR
CHILDREN AWAY.
THEY ARE IGNORING THE SCIENCE
THAT SAYS IT’S PERFECTLY OKAY TO
DO.
JESSE: I THINK HE SINGLE
AMERICAN WOULD BE THRILLED WITH
THAT NEWS.
KAYLEIGH MCENANY TANGLING WITH
ALL SORTS OF CHARACTERS ALL OVER